did you know california's gold rush was
the largest mass migration in american
history and more than 300 000 fortune
seekers flocked there between 1848 and
1852 so this is where the nickname the
golden state actually comes from now
today bankers are banking on what could
be a modern day gold rush right in the
middle of the mojave desert mark mester
dons a hard hat to see if a nearby mine
nicknamed the billion dollar oasis is
real or just a mirage
[Music]
if you've taken the 15 east you've
probably driven by this san bernardino
open pit mine and never knew what this
huge hole in the desert was or was worth
it's in the middle of nowhere it's
impossible to access and we're more than
500 feet down but it's what's inside
this mine that's powerful enough to fuel
all of our lives
outside of china there's only two scaled
rare earth production sites in the world
one of which is right here in san
bernardino county california to ensure
the united states has a high tech rock
solid future we're inside the largest
rare earth mine in the western
hemisphere some experts suggest this
massive mine 53 miles southwest of the
vegas strip is a sure bet for success
this is not just a pile of rocks this is
what miners
are pulling from the earth here in san
bernardino county these are the rare
earth minerals that go into everything
like your smartphone
or even your electric car a quick
chemistry lesson rare earths are
actually a group of 17 elements found on
the periodic table what is it that
you're showing us over here so this is
the dry tailings facility it's an
incredibly unique operation the purpose
of this facility is to remove your water
from your tailings and recycle it into
the process
hey mark let me show you uh some of
these uh fine ore pile
so
what starts as multi-ton rocks down in
the mine becomes one centimeter pebbles
here and essentially
inside this bassinocite fine ore there
are 17
special elements with special chemical
properties
the big rocks are a big deal because
when broken down they become a key and
critical component for computers
lasers batteries plus fighter jets
military weapons missile defense systems
and much more
the average person would be blown away
by how much we interact with rare earth
elements on a daily basis
without even realizing it at all though
the hard truth the us is considered just
a pebble in the giant global industry
with china dominating more than 80 of
the supply chain at the domestic level
it's it's very important to the us and
particularly in the us realizing its
ambitions towards electrifying its
vehicles and transitioning to greater
amounts of renewable energy experts
suggest if the us doesn't blast through
china's stranglehold the economy could
crack and future plans for green
technology clean air cars and even the
accuracy of weapons could power down so
the world is rapidly decarbonizing and
electrifying and it's imperative that we
have resilient adequate supplies of
these materials to enable industry and
government to move in that direction